لفحص كيف يبدو أن إسرائيل
تختبر الكثير من الأسلحة على الفلسطينيين
في
فلسطين الحرب في غزة أو في إسرائيل
مرة أخرى وضع مأساوي أه سيؤدي في
النهاية إلى أوامر إضافية أه
على الأرجح أه تركيزنا الآن هو
كيف ندعم الدفاع الإسرائيلي
القوة أه كيف نتأكد من أن
لديهم ما يحتاجونه ليكونوا قادرين على الدفاع عن
بلادهم
عريس RTX جنرال
دايناميكس الحرب من المتوقع أن تكلف
اقتصاد إسرائيل ما يقارب أه
200 مليار شيك أه هذا هو التقدير
للحدث بأكمله لكامل
الحرب
[الموسيقى] كانت
اختبارًا
أفضل
من
الكثير من الأسلحة التي استخدمتها إسرائيل في
السنوات الأخيرة ضد الفلسطينيين في غزة،
بما في ذلك في الواقع منذ 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، ليس
فقط الفسفور الأبيض، بل
شكل مختلف من الأسلحة التي تحرق
جلود الناس، لقد رأيت أدلة.  حول هذا الأمر
قبل 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، وبالتأكيد منذ ذلك الحين، على
الرغم من أنني لم أزور
غزة في الشهر الماضي، فقد رأيت الكثير من
التقارير من الصحفيين على الأرض،
معظمهم من الفلسطينيين، الذين يوضحون
أنهم غالبًا ما
يرون بيرنز وهو لا يرى ذلك.  تعرف على
الأطباء من المستشفيات في فلسطين
قائلين إننا لا نعرف كيفية علاج هذه
الإصابات، أعني أنه من الواضح أن هناك
كمية كبيرة الآن، وهناك نقص كبير في
المعدات الطبية بسبب الحرب ولكني
أقول إنهم يرون إصابات
لا يرونها  "لم أدرك أن ذلك يأتي من
أسلحة جديدة يتم اختبارها وكنت
مهتمًا بتأليف كتاب ليس فقط
حول ما يحدث في فلسطين
والذي من الواضح أنه سيئ بما فيه الكفاية بالنسبة
للفلسطينيين ولكن أيضًا شرح
الكشف عن التحقيق والتفصيل حول
عدد كبير جدًا من هذه الأسلحة بعد أن كانت
كذلك"  - تسمى معركة تم اختبارها في فلسطين وهو
المصطلح الذي تستخدمه الشركات الإسرائيلية والحكومة نفسها في كثير من الأحيان ويتم
بيعه في
جميع أنحاء العالم وقد قامت إسرائيل
بتطوير الكثير من
تقنيات الطائرات بدون طيار أه فوق غزة يستخدمونها
خلال ما يسمى بوقت السلم على الرغم من أنه من
الواضح أن الأمر ليس كذلك  سلمية بالنسبة
للفلسطينيين، ولكن عندما تكون هناك حرب
بين إسرائيل وحماس، فإن هذه الطائرات بدون طيار
تكون دائمًا على مدار الخمسة عشر عامًا الماضية هي
جوانب رئيسية
لاستهداف So-Cal لما تدعي إسرائيل أنهم
إرهابيون من حماس ولكن غالبًا ما يكونون
مدنيين فلسطينيين وتلك الطائرات بدون طيار
التي  تم اختبار المعركة في فلسطين في
غزة على الفلسطينيين ثم يتم بيعهم
وتسويقهم في جميع أنحاء العالم
وينتهي بهم الأمر في أماكن مثل الاتحاد الأوروبي.
أعتقد أن الأطروحة بطريقة ما ما كنت
أفعله منذ سنوات هي إظهار كيفية
احتلال فلسطين  يتم تصدير أن
ما يحدث في فلسطين ليس
بقاءه هناك مروعًا مثل
الاحتلال الذي يتعرض له الفلسطينيون في
حياتهم اليومية في الضفة الغربية وغزة
والقدس الشرقية، بل يبدو أن التكتيكات
والأدوات والهندسة القمعية
التي صممتها إسرائيل منذ عقود
هي الأطول  لقد انتهى الاحتلال في
العصر الحديث الآن في عدد لا يحصى من
الدول حول العالم في تلك الدول
التي ترغب في قمع
أقلياتها أو نشطاء حقوق الإنسان أو
الصحفيين أو المنشقين، ولكن فيما
يتعلق بقضية فلسطين، يبدو لي أنه من
المهم كوني يهوديًا علمانيًا أن أقوم بذلك.
لا تقل باسمي إنني أقول ما
تفعله إسرائيل وأدعي أنني أتحدث باسم
جميع اليهود في جميع أنحاء العالم وهو أمر
لا تقبله أعداد متزايدة من اليهود
[تصفيق]
إننا نشعر بالفزع والاشمئزاز
ونعارض الكثير مما تفعله إسرائيل
وبالنسبة لي، فإن ما آمل أن
أساهم به في تلك المحادثة والذي
أعتقد أن التحول في الرأي العام هو
توضيح أن هناك أعدادًا متزايدة
من اليهود الذين لا يدعمون إسرائيل ولا
يدعمون الاحتلال
ويعملون على معارضته في مجموعة متنوعة من المجالات.
طرق